well guys hopefully you're getting this
and i'm doing a little live stream here
to give you guys an
update um youtube has banned
comments on the outdoor boys youtube
channel uh if you've been following this
last week
there was um some
youtuber something claiming that
pedophiles were
watching harmless videos containing
children and
and uh making dirty comments and and
sharing with other sickos and
and uh this got picked up by buzzfeed
and some advertisers made a stink and
um about their wednesday last week
um uh youtube uh turned off the comments
to both my outdoor boys youtube channel
and the catfish and carp youtube channel
because of
um because you know my children
feature in the videos and what's
interesting is they did it to the entire
channel not just the videos that
that tommy and nathan are well
they did this last week um all they did
was change the settings and so
oh it was annoying but we went in and
changed the settings
back um and it was relatively fine it
was also strange they
also appeared to have been some glitch
in their system that turned off
monetization
for both my channels as well but i just
simply turned it back on
and and it seemed to be okay but anyway
um but yesterday night they
they again turned off the outdoor boys
youtube channel's comments
um and i cannot turn them on anymore
they permanently
i released without ability to do
anything about turned it off
um so i cannot receive comments um
or or anything as of uh
you know thursday night right so uh
um and this apparently has nothing to do
with um as far as i can tell i've gotten
no information and my youtube liaison
has not returned my
my emails and there was a link to a
to a public statement it was very vague
but my understanding is the only
reason they did this is because i have
children
my children feature in many of my videos
but they did it to my whole
whole channel um uh
and it's uh um
uh we'll see what happens um i'm i'm
hoping
that it's just a temporary stop gap
measure
until youtube finds a better solution
um something to just keep their
advertisers happy until they
do a better uh thing but i can't you
guys leave me
you can't leave me messages on the
outdoor boys youtube channel now
remember though we do have a facebook
page the outdoor boys and cats and car
both have their own facebook pages and
we both have
instagram accounts i have a twitter
account too but i never use it
yeah i never understood the purpose of
twitter but uh anywho um
uh so please you know oh uh post stuff i
i post
uh multiple times a week on instagram
facebook all that stuff so
um yeah and and you can
you can communicate with with me there
um
but i know a lot of people are wondering
what's up with that you know why are
our um why are are
our comments being disabled you know if
it's
you know me not wanting to listen to my
i uh
um you know you get no no no it's just
how it is now the other thing i wanted
to do this live stream is i wanted to
see
whether or not well thank you very much
alan walker
i is exactly what i wanted to see i am
seeing your comments
and i wanted to know whether or not
comments on live streams have been
disabled as well and it looks like they
haven't
so so far so good though that could
change
anytime now once i post this video
my suspicion is that after the live
stream people won't be able to comment
but i don't know
uh i will continue uploading videos um
uh and uh so you know they're they're
having demonetized
anything as far as i can tell so
i'll continue to upload i've got some
great videos coming i've got a metal
detecting video that's pretty fun
um uh coming up on the outdoor boys
channel in my
channel the catfishing cart channel i've
got some great ones
um i comments are scrolling by a little
fast i thought i might have seen mike
davis
as there um yeah mike chavez is a great
friend and fellow
well fishing youtuber and uh he
and many of our other colleagues we
featured in the video
i'm on pins and needles though i have a
great catfish and cart video i wanted
you guys um
hey thank you very much that is uh
ancient tree growth ghost thank you for
your for your support i appreciate that
and
and uh i went to the catfish conference
so what was it
uh end of february and uh we did a
really fun video i brought a bunch
of european carp gear i thank you tim i
appreciate that
i brought a lot of european cart gear to
the catfish conference and i got to sit
down with chris flores and
mike chavez and and uh luke from
northwood angling and a bunch of other
are
catfishermen and some fans and i gotta
uh i
hand them this european carp gear and do
a
catfisherman react to uh european carp
gear
or uh video and it i i wasn't 100
sure how it was going when i was filming
it but when i got done with the editing
it it just absolutely busted me up
um uh dylan thank you very much i
appreciate the support
so super fun video on catfish and carp
so if you guys don't know
um in case this is just some outdoor
boys youtube channel fans here i have
two channels i'll
actually have several others but two
that um
that are this kind of genre i have a
fishing
channel called catfish and carp and i
have uh the
outdoor boys channel hey mike oh mike
chavez was one of the best people
interviewed on that whole thing
he was he he made the video him and
chris flores and peter
were hilarious um terry uh uh
uh terry with monster hot holders was
great too
um oh hey thank you i
i appreciate all the support guys um you
know i'm
it always makes me nervous you know i i
see all the time people posting
especially here
in the outdoors uh sporting
genre you know a lot of us are concerned
because you know youtube is
taking certain stances on gun videos and
uh
hunting videos and and there's a lot of
anxiety amongst youtube creators who are
fishermen and hunters and gun
enthusiasts
and other similar genres that you know
where they're being demonetized
and uh um somebody asked what the other
channel is car
called catfish and carp but uh um
uh it's and i have been fortunate i have
about
600 videos that i've uploaded between
these two channels
and then i have another almost 100
videos that i've done on my law firm
youtube channel
um and and i i've only have
one video that has been demonetized out
of 600
i have hunting videos i have a few
videos that feature guns and shooting
i have some trapping videos you know
um all that stuff uh and i uh and
i've only had one and that was the video
that tommy did
that's got over 10 million views on the
outdoor boys channel
where he rode his bike down the driveway
and we did this kind of fun little
click bait thing where we had tommy
covered in stage blood lying on the
ground like he'd been
horribly mangled in an accident and they
said that the the
thumbnail because it looked like a child
had been
injured seriously injured um violated
their monetization policy and that's the
only video
that i have that's been demonetized so
all the hunting videos i
did a squirrel hunting video and i
butchered a squirrel and everything
and uh thank you sean very much for that
donation thank you
um so for for those of you creators out
there that are worried about it
my they aren't the youtube is they they
they're the rules are evolving all right
and because they're evolving it makes us
all nervous about what's going to happen
next but also it's made
youtube so they aren't very specific
they've also been a little bit vague so
that they can
change their mind you know if something
weird comes up
um and uh
but but the things that i've noticed is
if you kill an
animal on camera you're uh kill an
animal not a fish or a crustacean
but an animal on camera you're going to
be in trouble
there's a gentleman who runs a youtube
channel where he just does
mouse trapping where he catches mice and
mousetraps and i've heard him made that
comment as well
and i when back in 2017
when this whole demonetization thing
started
i had a video on how to catch and cook
blue crabs
and we went out and caught crabs and
then we dumped them in a pot and boiled
them up and ate them
and it showed the crabs being dumped in
the pot and that video
was demonetized and i appealed it and
i've had a lot of videos demonetized but
you appeal it
and in a day or two they they remonetize
it it's just the
the computer programs mistake type thing
and i i
appealed that one and they did a human
uh
review and they said nope that violates
our policy and for six months that video
was demonetized
until um the fall about you know you
know
six months later and then out of the
blue without me doing anything it was
remonetized and i think that was an
example where there are no killing
animals on camera policy
they they extended that to crabs being
boiled
and then um and then they had an
internal change in policy
and went back and undid
that demonetization um
so oh i think that's
you know that's kind of some of the
evolution we're seeing and of course
as sports fishermen i'm very very
concerned that one day they're going to
decide that
that harming fish on camera is animal
cruelty
and demonetize it and that's a real
that's a real concern and that could
happen
but i don't know it could not could
either way
um and it's it's a shame too because
there's people like me where you know i
could
do youtube full-time if i wanted to but
i will
i'm not going to because i have three
small kids and a wife
thank you very much guys tech and toys
and and
uh sorrento oh thank you for the support
i appreciate but i i'm not gonna do
youtube full time because
any moment i could wake up and my
channels could be gone and the money
from them could be gone
and then what's my wife and kids gonna
i've built a law firm
i'm a senior partner at a law firm i you
know it's been good to me
and and uh i can do both youtube and
the law firm stuff um and you know i'm
just not going to
give up that and walk away from that
to do a job that could disappear at any
moment without
any explanation or justification
and uh and it's it's too bad because i
know a lot of
um a lot of you uh would would like to
do professional youtubing and this has
got to give people pause
you know and there's a lot you know it's
a significant
investment in time and energy before it
becomes profitable and if you're going
to work two three years on building a
channel
with the hopes of doing this full time
you must realize that it may not be
there
two three years from now um but uh
um but we'll see um we'll see
there's uh you know i'm not as
pessimistic as people are um you can
still have
uh guns and hunting videos and be
monetized and do that
but there are some very specific lines
and if you cross them
youtube will demonetize you i know a
demolition ranch i've heard him
mention uh several times that his gun
bullet making videos
were demonetized so for some making
custom bullets
uh where he'd pack shotgun shells full
of random crap and shoot it out of a gun
see what happens
those videos got demonetized um so
you know there's really weird unspoken
unwritten rules
and you kind of have to figure them out
either by being so big that you can call
up
youtube and get somebody on the phone to
tell you
um or you have to hey thank you very
much uh canuck
appreciate that yeah five canadian bucks
too we got international currency man
thank you
um uh so you either gotta be big enough
that you can pick up the phone and call
youtube or shoot an email and get a live
person to respond to you
or you got to do trial and error but
there are very specific rules
and if you know what they are you can
you can stay
out of trouble but the the main point of
this
this live stream and it's not going to
be terribly long is is
i just wanted to to let you guys know
that i didn't turn off
the comments on the outdoor boys channel
uh dulce will warn you that this could
happen at any hour
any moment now cats and carp could be
hey their comments will turn on i expect
it will be
probably you know i just think they for
whatever reason the computer hasn't
gotten around to it
you know maybe because it doesn't have
the word boys in the title you know
but uh um but anyway so if that happens
please you know oh make sure you guys
follow me on facebook and instagram so
that we can
we can go back and forth um if this
continues long term you know my rod
giveaways
and all my contests will have to be on
facebook
um i'm also going to be posting um some
posts in the comment
the community section of my youtube
channels to kind of experiment and see
if i can still get feedback through that
so i'm going to try to post something
um on that as well just to experiment
and see
what what features still work and what
um
do a hunting broccoli video nice
you butcher it on camera then like fuzz
the roots out and stuff you know and
have like green stuff squirt on my face
i like this honey broccoli okay i might
i might table that
actually guys i've got some a lot of
really kind of
controversial oh hey thank you i got
some pounds from lee
this is a very international live chat i
appreciate this
cheers oh and lee make sure you watch
that american fisherman
responding to british carp gear video on
katz's car probably a week from tomorrow
you're going to enjoy that that's going
to it's going to be great um
but yeah i've got some oh i got a video
right now
that is so freaking funny that i don't
know if i can post it though it's a
little
a little dark and i know a lot of
parents watch my videos with their kids
and
it's i don't want to i don't want to
ruin that um
but i i can't i did i got a video that's
like half
done it's called the momo fishing
challenge based off this
internet hoax you know the the momo
internet
it's basically this really creepy dark
thing about this
this this um
creepy character that tells kids to do
self-harm and stuff like that and it's
it's a really horrible thing
fortunately it's not a real challenge
that no one's really actually doing it
but
um i decided to do a spoof on that
making fun of it
and basically do the momo fishing
challenge where basically momo comes and
tells me to do these really bizarre
fishing challenges and
do a little skit with that but it's
actually really really funny but um
and also i have a big bag of severed
python heads for my python hunting video
that i want to go
catfishing with so i figured i could
mesh those two together
i don't know if i want to go there after
after after this
um
i'm gonna put links in the video
description for
my instagram pages and my facebook pages
for both
both channels guys so you can uh you can
see that
um uh
any rate um uh but uh yeah anyway i'm
not sure what's up with banning the
comments
and uh it seemed to me like a much more
reasonable solution
um was there's a feature when you create
a channel you can have comments either
posted or you can have comments turned
off
or you can have comments held for review
and i do this on my law firm channel
because i don't
go and and follow it all the time i
don't go and check in every day
um and so you can have it where all the
comments are held off
until you approve them and then post
them which seems like this is the great
solution that just
automatically turn my comments into hell
to review and then that way no
no sickos get get through hey thanks for
dkk 17 i don't even know what that is
but thank you
angelese oh um
so any uh what's my law firm channel my
law firm channel is boring unless you've
been arrested for
dui but it's a nichols and green okay
but uh
um uh
so anyway i thought that would have been
a much much better solution than just
turning off comments altogether and
and i don't know what it is because i
follow i i if you guys notice my
um my uh
my channel i monitor comments very
carefully i try to keep
the comments as family friendly as this
channel so that
you know people don't have to worry
about uh danish krone well thank you
angelis i appreciate that
um so uh so yeah i mean i watch
i every comment that's posted i read i
can't respond to them because i get like
300 a day so i mean i just physically
can't respond to all of them but
i i filter them aggressively you know i
i mean
and i communist china ain't got nothing
on me when it comes to stifling free
speech but
um yeah anybody anything dirty or using
swear words or nasty
or who annoys me too much i just get rid
of them
and i usually do that multiple times a
day i go through and
check it so there's been no issues with
dirty comments coming up but
still here i am and they are even doing
it on videos when there's no kids in the
videos but
what can you do so um i'll keep you guys
up to date i
i'm i'm hopefully we'll hear back from
my youtube liaison
about what's happening but in the
meantime i want to let you guys know
oh that i'm not ignoring you that this
is just something that's happening for
right now
and uh also we've got some fun videos
coming up
so uh oh yes oh what
why hello what's what's this
yeah that's coming out soon um
yeah that's some more fun videos
and uh i've got one that i'm working on
too
it's like seven best way to destroy your
kid
video game console let me know if you
think that'll be fun to watch i've got
some great ideas
um
lawyers don't have to work on fridays
actually i just got out of court or uh
i've done
three three cases days uh
uh this morning already and uh i am very
good at my job
and i have successfully defended all
three clients and it's uh
by hannah was done by 1 30. that's
that's why you charge flat rate not
hourly
ah i'm glad you like the uh
yak attack sports don't do that please i
don't have a clue what you're talking
about
what's your favorite thing about being a
lawyer i love my
clients actually i really enjoy my
clients i
they're most most people get in trouble
with the law are good people who've just
made mistakes
um you know i don't tend to represent uh
a ton of like you know child molesters
and stuff like that
you know i have some experience with
that but you know but still most my
clients are
are just good people who are
having horrible time in their life and
they just need one person to be in their
corner
and to listen to them and help them and
to just
help them out and it's really nice when
someone comes in my office freaked out
e-r-r-k-25 thank you very much hey thank
you thank you very much i appreciate the
message as well
um anyway i just really i just love it
when someone calls
me up and they're just freaking out of
their mind and i talk to her for an hour
and by the end
they're they they're okay they realize
their their life's not ended they're
gonna be okay and i get to help people
and you you never realize the stress
that people go through i've had multiple
clients commit suicide
um i've had multiple people call me up
and tell me they're gonna kill
themselves um
i represent me and my partner about 600
people a year
um so you know you see it just destroys
people's lives and to be able to help
them
and just make another human being's life
um a little less miserable it's a
pleasure
it's a very comforting thing oh i'm
going well
oh have you ever caught redfish and
black drum
no i haven't but i'm hoping to go to the
outer banks and get into some drum
this spring that sounds fun i hope you
go catch some great ones seth thank you
very much for the donation
um uh any rate
uh uh so yeah i really enjoy my job um
you know and it's and it's great hours
as you can tell you know
somebody once joked that uh um being a
criminal defense attorney is the best
part-time job they ever had
anyway um listen guys i've gotta cut it
short um i'm gonna go
uh i've gotta go meet a few people but
uh i'm glad to see that we can still
interact through live streams
and stay tuned guys we got some great
videos coming up tomorrow morning
thanks for watching guys